[Müzik]
Merhabalar herkese
ismim Zeynel
müzikle başlayıp müzikle bitirmeyi
düşünüyorum şimdi bir türkü çalacağım ve
bu türkünün bağlamını size konuşmanın
içerisinde anlatmayı çalışacağım
[Müzik]
geldim Şu Alemi
ıslah edin
ıslah edeyim
[Müzik]
sonra
gördüm son moda
öldüğünü meydanda
gördüm son
da
zaman
la pek
dost
Neyleyim ilah
[Müzik]
i
gönlümü verdi
sermayemden sorarsa
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Şimdi benim için tarihi günler oluyor
hayatımda
Perşembe günü bize gazhanede iklim
Müzesinde çaldım bir müzik ses ve iki
aktivisti olarak çok kıymetli bir
konserdi benim için dün
İngiltere'den bir plak şirketinden
dünyanın en önemli Word müzik plak
şirketlerinden birinden albümüm çıktı ve
Anadolu ve Türkiye'nin
14 yüzyıldan günümüze kadar
Adaletine türküler üzerinden anlatmaya
çalıştım pek çok aşık O sana ve albümün
sonuna doğru bir besleme yer verdim
divanen Divan albümünün
iklim ve müzik aktivizmi üzerine
konuşmak için buradayım tdx'teyim
mükemmel bir 3 gün oluyor benim için
şimdi beni buraya getiren
hikaye Aslında önemli an Ya da anı iklim
aktivistleri ve iklim aktivizmi için bir
beste yapmıştım ben yıllar önce ilk defa
tanıştığım zaman bu kavramlarla ya da
derinlemesine inceleme ve okuma yapmaya
başladığım zamanlarda
sonra Bu mesleğin ismi sesi ol finalde
de dostlarımla birlikte onun çalacağız
sizlere
Hatta şu an video klibinde izliyorsunuz
Orçun Kara Mustafa dostum çekmişti bu
klibi
Nietzsche nietche'yi okuduğum Böyle
Buyurdu zerdüşte okuduğum zamandı ve o
zamanlar felsefe öğrenciliğimin felsefe
lisans öğrencilerimin ilk yıllarıydı pek
çok nitek kitabı gibi çok fazla
heyecanla
okuduğum bir kitaptı ancak kitap beni
bir ilginç etkiledi daha önce de daha
çocukluk yaşlarında tanışmıştım kitapla
ama ilginç bir derinlik kurduk kurdum
kitapla Bu kitapta pek çoğunuz
biliyordur işte bir zerdüş var ve
Mağarasında dağlarda yaşıyor ve sonra
artık ovaya inme şehre inme kararı
veriyor ve biraz budanın hikayesine de
benziyor ve bu sırada Tabii ki bir sürü
şeye Tanık oluyor Bir sürü hikaye
geçiyor Başına ve bir sürü Aforizma ve
büyük fikirlerle Bizi tanıştırıyor kendi
kurgularının başka kurgularla olan
çarpışmalarını görüyoruz zararı düştüğün
yolculuğunda ve sonra zerdüş kitabın bir
inde güneşle konuşuyor ve bu bu diyalog
bu iletişim beni inanılmaz etkilemişti
Ondan sonra ben de bu etkiyle bir beste
yaptım ve hatta ikinci kıta sayıda 2
kıtasında şöyle söylüyorum dağları
Zerdüşt Dolanır ovada bir kuş uyanır gün
gelir zalimin uykusuna sevdanın düşü
bulanır diyorum sesi ol sesi ol sesi ol
sönmeyen ateşin sesi ol sesi ol sesi ol
yükselen güneşin diyorum buradaki şarkı
anlatmak biraz tehlikeli bir iş ama
bence bu aktivist şarkılarda ya da böyle
ideolojik ya da devrimci diyebileceğimiz
şarkılar da bence bu arka planlar
faydalı olabiliyor ya da bizi daha çok
heyecanlandırıyor normalde böyle bu
Beste şunun için yazıldı ve Bu şarkını
göndermesi bu şu kızı seviyordum ve ona
yazdım falan gibi şeyler tehlikeli
olabiliyor ama bu türkü bu Beste için bu
şarkı için biraz farklı olduğunu
düşünüyorum çünkü kendini böyle
açabilecek bir Üründü O benim için zaten
Buradaki
yükselen Güneş nicelin karşılaştığı
konuştuğu Güneş ve sönmeyen ateşte gene
Güneş ve güneşin bir
çocuğu evladı olarak dünya yer yüzüydü
dünya onayla burasıydı
Ancak ben bu mesleği yaptıktan sonra
yıllar geçti üzerine düşünmeye başladım
ondan sonra
[Müzik]
pandemin hemen çıkışında
2001-2021 pardon yaz aylarında
arkede bir fikir kampında müzik
felsefesi ve ses felsefesi üzerine
konuşma yapmaya gittim orada aslıhan'la
tanıştım ve o beni iklim aktivizmi
hareketlerine davet etti ve sonra
mükemmel güzel insanlar geleceğin güzel
çocuklarıyla tanıştım tanışmaya başladım
oralarda
Melisa ile tanıştığım iklim öncüleriyle
tanıştım pek çok başka kişiyle birlikte
tanıştım
sonra ben de onlara dedim ki benim
yıllar önce yazdığım bir beste var iklim
aktivizmi için ve böyle acaba nasıl olur
Bunu birlikte yapsak koray'ı oluşturmaya
çalıştık falan olmadı Herkesin çok
yoğunluğu var herkes dünyayı kurtarmaya
çalışıyor Yaşasın ki
tam tutturamadık ama böyle güzel bir
şeyler oldu derken biz de ondan sonra 24
Eylül 2021'deki etkinlikti Bu iklim
grevine iklim mitingine davet edilmiştik
ve Orçun'a dedim O da benim pek çok
videomu ve fotoğraflarımı çeken kıymetli
dostum acaba gidip oranın sesi mi olsak
dedim bu besteyle ve oradaki görüntüyü
de kendi klibimize mi alsak dedim ve
sonra
oraya daldık içerisinde daldık bu güzel
etkinliğin
Sonra işte video süreci ve vesaire
herkes herkesin enerjisinin için içine
girdiği bir video klip ve şarkı olmuş
oldu Türkiye iklim aktivizmi çalışmaları
içerisinde de umarım
ne yazık ki kriz büyüdükçe ama
hareketler çoğaldıkça daha da kendini
bulacağını hissettiğimi düşündüğüm bir
iş çıkarmış olduk hep birlikte Zaten her
yerde söylüyorum ve sonsuz
teşekkürlerim olsun Bütün bu çalışmalara
ancak
geçen yıl
Güneş ve Aşık Veysel yalıydı belki
tanıtımı okumuşsunuzdur orada şey
yazmıştım ya da yazmaya çalışmıştım
doğayı alemi insanı
her şeyi türküler üzerinden anlamaya
çalışan biriyim anlamaya çalışmak
isteyen biriyim türkülerin büyük
öğretileri ve derinlikleri içerisinde
pek çok
güçlü iz bu formül bulabiliriz nasıl
yaşayacağımız gurbete gittiğimizde nasıl
davranacağımız sular kirlendiğinde neler
yapmamız gerektiği dosttan ayrı
Düştüğümüzde Yardan Ayrı Düştüğümüzde ne
yapmamız gerektiğini pek çok şeyin
türkülerden çıkarmaya çalışıyorum ya da
zaten türküler benim kültürümde Benim
geldiğim Aşık Ozan geleneğinde zaten
ninniler gibi ve onları ben hep böyle
dinlemişim ve Zaten onlar hep arka
bellekte ya da kültürel kodlarında var
ve zaten gerekli yerde de kendini dışarı
çıkarıyor gibiler sonra Aşık Veysel'in
makalesini de belki içgüdüsel Belki bu
konuyu kafaya taktığım için
ya da her şey beni oraya sürüklediği
için bir akış ve bir rüzgar halinde
Hiçbir türlü Hiçbir türlü bulamadım ben
beni türküsü üzerine yazdım yazmak
istedim makale Aşık Veysel aşıklık
ozanlık aşkınlık ve kendilik
kavramlarını tartıştığım bir makaleydi
bu
Süleyman Şenel hocamız itü'den Süleyman
Şener hocamızın editörlüğünü yaptığı
güçlü önemli bir kitap oldu Belki
karşılaşmışsınızdır
bu kitapta makaleyi yazarken Ve tabii ki
bu türkü o türkü ve başka türküler
üzerine düşünürken böyle son kıta beni
inanılmaz çekti ve böyle bana bir şeyler
söylemeye başladı türkünün son kıtasında
Üstat Aşık Veysel Üstad diyor ki
varlığın yokluğun bir Veysel adım Gök
kubbede kalacaktır ses Kadim 53 yıl
kendi kendim aradım Hiçbir türlü
bulamadım ben beni şimdi bu kıtada beni
çeken çok fazla yer var Çünkü zaten
kendilik problemi insan insan olabilmek
doğanın hakkını verebilmek dünyanın
hakkını verebilmek zaten bizim
ulaşabileceğimiz yerler değil diye
düşünenler diyelim bunlar bir İdea ve
biz gittikçe uzaklaşıyor Tıpkı kendilik
gibi
daha iyi bir insan olmak mümkün ama
mükemmel bir insan yoktur diye
düşünenler dedim ki birazdan Hayde
Gerede dayanacağım
burada ama bir şekilde
insan kendini bulamayabilir ama dünyayı
anlamaya çalışmak alemi anlamaya
çalışmaktan geri durmamalı ve bunun için
bir aktivist ve bir eylemci önce kendine
karşı bir aktivist ve eylemci olabilmesi
mümkün ve bu insanı kendiliğe
ulaştırmasa da kendiliğine
yaklaştırabilecektir Elbette diye
düşünüyorum
şöyle düşünüyorum Yani bazen pek çoğunuz
gibi böyle dertli bir günümde Hadi
kendimi iyi edeyim diye bir boş arayışa
düşerim Ve Aslında insanın kendisini iyi
etmesinin pek mümkünüdür Olmaz diye bir
Kanada kanaate vardığım yerdeyim ama
gidip bir sokaktaki bir köpeğe
belki sadece anlık bir rahatlama bile
olsa iyilik yapmak böyle bana hiç
değilse bana hala özel yerden konuşuyor
da olabilirim bir köpeğe iyi olmaya
çalışmak bir insana yardım etmeye
çalışmak Bence kendine yapılabilir
kendine yapabileceğimiz kendimize
yapabileceğimiz en iyi iyilik ve
kendimiz bu dünyadaki
ilk fark ettiğimiz evimiz kendimiz bu
bedenimiz ve bir başkası da bir diğeri
de sadece sanki dünya olabilir diye
düşünüyorum Bu gökkubbe bu Gök kubbeden
daha büyük daha kıymetli bir evimiz yok
ve eve sahip çıkmanın yolu da galiba eve
iyi olmaya çalışmak
bu Gök kubbede başka bir şey daha var
beni kendisine çok çeken ben ses
aktivizm aktivizliyimin bir miktarında
ses mühendisi ya da ses teknisyeni
olarak müzik sektöründe çalıştığım
yıllarda ya da dışarıdaki çeşitli
örtülü eylemlerde de yaptım ses
teknolojileri ile ilgileniyorum
10-15 yıl gibi bir süredir ve ses
kavramı zaten benim için Ekstra önemli
bir kavram ama Üstad diyor ki gök
kubbede kalacaktır ses Kadim şimdi bütün
yaptığımız eylemlerin hareketlerin
yapabileceğimiz bütün güzel şeylerin bu
dünyada ancak bir ses olabileceğini ya
da güzel bir Ötmek bir kuş gibi şak Amak
olabileceğini bana söyleyen bir Aşık
Ozan geleneği var ve bu öğüt yıllardır
Kulaklarıma dolardı ve giderek de
derinleşmeye başladı ve tam da bugünkü
konuşma artık benim her şeyi belki
kesinleştiremesem de Açmaya çalıştığım
yer olarak bugün burada hayatımın belki
süregelen üçüncü önemli günlerinden
birisi
ve sonra aşıklık Ozan geleneğindeki ses
kavramı üzerine biraz daha düşünmeye
Türk
mitozlarındaki Ötmek ve kuş olmak kuş
gibi şakamak cihana ötmeye gelmek gibi
böyle kavramlar metaforlar üzerine biraz
daha düşürmeye başladım
Fakat bunların hepsi aslında böyle sesi
ol sesi olduğunu için yazdığımı da bana
söylüyor Aslında ben diyorum ki ben bir
güneş ve bir zerdüş konuşmasına tanık
oldum ve bir sesi ol yazdım Hayır
aslında arkada çok daha derin Kolektif
bilincimize Anadolu kültüründeki belki
işte bugünün moda kavramıyla karmatik
durumlarıma uzanan bir şey olduğunu
hissediyordum bu besteyi araştırırken ve
sonra şunu da fark ettim
Tam da
Son 3 dakika mı Hadi ya aman Allah'ım 18
dakika dün geçmiyordu bugün hızlı
geçiyor
O Zaman hızlıca geliyorum
bu başta söylediğim türküde
geldim Şu Alemi ıslah edeyim
Özümü meydanda gördüm sonradan zaman
mahlukuna mailimi verdim sermayemden
zarar gördüm sonradan diyen türkünün
Aslında dünyayı ıslah etmeye geldiğini
zanneden insanın bu modern insanın
dünyanın sahibi Efendisi zanneden
insanın bir hikayesini anlatıyor gibiydi
ve sonra tam da gene sesioğlu yazdığım
yıllarda
felsefeciliğimin ilk yılında Hayde gel
çalışmaya başladım ve bir baktım ki çok
ilginç halde Eğer 1800
89'da noksani bu değişim türkünün yazarı
da
1899 yılında birbirinden onar yıllarıyla
başka coğrafyalarda doğmuş insanlar ve
Hayde geldi diyor ki
insan varlığın çobanıdır varlığı gütmeye
gelmiştir diyor ilginç bir şekilde
varlığı ıslah etme ama bir daha bir şey
daha söylüyor Hale gel insan var
olanının Efendisi değildir Bu nehirlerin
suyun ırmağın dağın taşın Efendisi
değildir İnsan var olanının efendisi
değil varlığın çobanıdır diyordu Ve
sonra Bütün bunların benim içimde
oldukça güçlü bir yer tutmaya tuttuğunu
fark etmeye başladım ve sonra giderek
tekrardan akışı yeterse getirecek
olursam Aşık Ozan gelenin üzerine daha
fazla
düşünme ve çalışmayı başlarken Aşık
Veysel makalesinde bana gösterdiği yol
üzerinden ilerlemeye gittim ve biraz
yüksek lisans çizimin gene ses ve müzik
felsefesi çalıştım yüksek lisans tezimin
de etkisi vardı tam o dönemlerde
bir anda aklıma mahsulinin şu sözleri
geldi
bana gel gel olursa yüceden
çırpar kanadını Uçar giderim diyor yani
kuş olmaya öykülen bir Mahsuni var orada
ya da diğer sözünde Üstad diyor ki
ölçmek istiyorum viranbağalarda Ayağıma
cennet kiralansa da herhalde burada Adem
ile Havva mitosuna da gönderme yapıyor
Üstat ve diyor ki bu burası bize
buradaki Viran Bağlar belki Viran
eylediğimiz Bağlar Evet dünyayı kötü bir
yer yaptık yapıyoruz ama bu Viran
bağlarda ötmeye geldik ve bunların
hepsinin bir böyle var olma çabası bir
eylem bir kendilik eylemi bir daha iyi
bir insan olmak bir kuş olmak Ötmek
burada burayla uyumlu hale gelmek
üzerinde kurulduğunu ve kurgulandığını
düşünüyorum ve sonra biraz daha detaylı
derilere gittiğim zaman eski Türk
mitoslarında İslam'la tanışmadan önce
Türklerin Cennet kavramının uçma
olduğunu öğreniyorum uçmanın kendisi bir
cennete düşme hali ve ruhumuz bir kuş
olarak nitelendirilir pek çok yerde
karşınıza çıkmıştır ruhumuz bir kuş
olarak
yükselir Uçar ve tencereye karışır eski
Türk inançlarında ve mitozlarında böyle
söylenir ve bu uçuş Belki de içerimizin
kuş olarak bildiğimiz şeyin acaba
kendisideki ötmekle de bağlantı olarak
ses midir demeye başladım kendime ve
insanın canının
ses olabileceğini düşünmeye başladım
Çünkü Ölüm anında bir şey oluyor
bedenimizi orada görüntüsü değişiyor
belki kokusu değişiyor vesaire ama bir
şey eksiliyor Ölüm anında ses artık
Kalbimiz atmıyor artık ses çıkarma
faaliyetimizden faaliyetinden yoksunuz
bizden karşı bir ötekiye insana
ulaşabilecek bir ses mümkün değil artık
acaba ruhumuzun varlığımızın kaynağın
üstadların da aşık ozanlarında büyük
ihtimalle Kadim dönenlerden beri ki
türkülerin köklerini oralarda olduğunu
düşünenler benim bende acaba üstadlar
bize içerimizdeki canın ses olduğunu mu
söylüyorlardı ve ben de eğer dünyayı
gene bir nişan göndermesi olsun Tanrı
öldü Şimdi bu kanlı Ellerinize ne
yapacak ne yapacağız dediği o meşhur
çıkış ve ben de acaba
dünya ölmekte ve dünyanın sesi eksiliyor
ve acaba dünyanın doğanın sesi olabilir
miyiz dediğini düşündüm ya da kendimi
tersten okuduğumda bunu buldum ve bu
yüzden sesi ol bestesinin başka bir
şekilde konumlanabileceğini düşündüm ve
bugün de benim için orasıydı Umarım bu
dünyanın doğanın güzel sesleri olan bu
güzel çocuklarla bu etkinliğin
kurucuları ile birlikte Daha güzel
ötüşebiliriz gelecek bizim
ötüşlerimizle güzel seslerimize daha da
fazla yankılanır bu günden ve şimdiden
diyorum
[Alkış]
şimdi müzikle başladım ve müzikle
bitirelim demiştim Hemen peşine
bağlayalım dostlarım burada Ergin ve
Yarkın Ergin Kandemir ve Erkin Sezgin
alkışlarınızla onları sahneye davet
ediyorum
[Müzik]
böyle gelmiş böyle gidersem var
kaldırıyorum
havaya
Zalim olan hep kazanmış Ama sen de susma
haykır onlara
Zalim
[Müzik]
ol aklın
La diyor
sönmeyen ateşi
Sisi yok Sisi yok sesi yok
yükselen güneşim
Sessiz ol sesi at sesi yok
[Müzik]
sönmeyen
sesi yok
[Müzik]
La La La La La La La La La La La La La
La La La La La La La La
[Müzik]
la la
La La La La La
La
La La La
[Müzik]
dağları
zerdüştlanır
olada bir kuş uyanır
dal
[Müzik]
danın hali uykusuna Sevdanın
lüksü yok sesi
yok
[Müzik]
sönmedi o ses
yok
[Müzik]
sesi yok sesi yok
Sende Yan Ateşi
yok
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Teşekkürler bu gece için bugün için
Pardon alıştık gece hayatına Teşekkürler
bugün için burayı kuranlar Emeği geçen
herkese sonsuz teşekkürler dünyanın
doğanın güzelliklerin sesi olmaya devam
Umarım iyi ki varsınız var olun
[Alkış]
Hadi bir de selam o zaman kırmızı halı
selamı